It's great to welcome Neil Ferguson to the
program today.
He's a historian and senior fellow at the
Hoover Institution whose new PBS series Net
World explores the history and science of
networks.
Neil, it's so great to have you on.
I appreciate it.
Thank you, David.
Great to be with you.
So to start with, as as a historian or an
historian, as different people love to argue
about, that's not what I want to ask you about.
But as a historian, is the idea that things
have then surely always sort of go back to
feeling the way we remember them feeling is
an inevitability?
Or could we really now be in sort of a situation
that marks a before and after that will be
important in the lives of people who are living
right now?
Well, yeah, that's a great question to ask
an historian or a historian.
And in London, it's easy as an historian because
you don't say the H age, right?
It's a good question to ask historian, because
really we are in a position to look at past
pandemics and see the extent to which they
they changed the way people lived and thought
we forget.
I suspect how frequent pandemics were in the
past and how exposed populations words are
contagious lethal diseases.
For example, in the 19th century, cholera
regularly swept through major cities on both
sides of the Atlantic, but particularly in
Europe.
If you go back a little further, smallpox
was the problem that people had to deal with
in their early American colonies and even
subsequently.
And if you want to go all the way back to
the Middle Ages, you had the dreadful problem
of bubonic and pneumonic plague, which we
call the Black Death.
I think it's fair to say that these great
pandemics with really high mortality did change
things.
That is to say, people altered their behavior
and they they didn't interact in the way they
had before for some time subsequently.
If you read Daniel Defoe on the Great London
Plague of 16 65, he talks about the ways in
which people had to become less trusting of
even people that they they knew.
And there's an interesting piece of research
on the long lasting impacts of the 1918 19
influenza pandemic, which really seems to
have affected trust in those countries that
were most badly affected by the pandemic.
On the other hand, if you look at what we're
going through now, it's not as bad a pandemic
as those.
It's not likely to kill as large a share of
the population as, say, the Black Death, which
killed perhaps a third of humanity, and even
the influenza pandemic of 1918, 19 killed
between two and three percent of people.
This is not going to be by any means as disastrous.
And so we probably won't be as as strongly
impacted.
Actually, I think the economic measures we've
taken, in particular the lockdown's, will
probably have had a bigger impact than the
disease itself, precisely because the disease
is so heavily concentrated on certain groups.
It's so much more likely to kill elderly people
than the young, which makes it very different
from other pandemics.
So to cut a very long story short, I would
say the best analogy might actually be with
a recent pandemic which operated in different
ways but killed a great many people.
HIV AIDS, HIV AIDS changed the way people
behaved sexually and I think covered 19 will
change the way people behave socially in somewhat
similar ways, especially if there's no vaccine
in a reasonably short time frame.
And that's a big and crucial variable.
If there is a vaccine, if it's rapidly discovered,
if it works really well.
And it's generally available this time next
year, then I'm not sure that our behavior
will radically change over the long term.
But if that vaccine doesn't turn up, then
I think you can see big changes in social
behavior, somewhat similar to the changes
in sexual behavior that came after HIV AIDS.
So you mentioned trust, and I'm interested
in hearing a little bit about, you know, when
we think about the effect of networks and
networks in which we are participants or involved
in, so to speak.
What is your sense of the factors that most
are influencing, the individual decisions
people are making about?
Do I go out in protest or not against the
lockdown's or against police brutality?
Do I wear a mask or don't I wear a mask, et
cetera?
Is it about who is in your personal network?
Is it about the news you consume?
Is it about what the CDC says?
If you are part of a certain network but not
part of another with your sense of that.
That's a great question.
David, the way I think about this is that
there are really two pandemics going on concurrently.
One is the biological pandemic where a new
corona virus source called two spreads around
the world very rapidly and creates all kinds
of dislocations as well as excess mortality.
But there's this other pandemic of information,
disinformation, misinformation that is going
on online.
And in some ways, some of that contagion is
even more rapid and it spread an extensive
spread.
You're actually more likely to encounter that
viral nonsense about Kov at 19, then covered
19 itself because the second pandemic spreads
much more rapidly.
And you can catch a wrong idea from the Internet,
which which you can't do with the virus.
It requires you to be in the same physical
space as a carrier.
So I think the second pandemic is really interesting
because it makes a huge difference to your
experience and your assessment of risk, how
you are networks to the rest of the world.
If you are the kind of person who gets information
from mainstream media who perhaps is quite
selective in what you read.
Perhaps you are dip into quality newspapers
in more than one country and carefully filter
roads, click bait.
Then you'll form the view, as I would say
I have, that this pandemic ain't over.
And if you are particularly in an older age
group, you should not be rushing into crowded
situations, even if they're outdoors.
But if your somebody who gets information
from a very different set of sources, perhaps
you're very exposed to the kind of influences
on the far left or the far right who are very
likely to circulate misinformation and disinformation.
You might form the conclusion either that
this thing is over and we should just be getting
right back to normal, which is certainly a
widespread view in some quarters.
Or you might think, well, it's still an issue,
but I should be much more outraged about social
justice questions and therefore I should protest
because somehow or other, the virus is going
to give me a break if I'm doing something
virtuous.
So it depends very heavily where you are in
a world where information is no longer mainly
distributed by terrestrial television stations,
as it was, say, back in the 60s, a world in
which information is channeled through very
complex networks in which influences some
of whom you may never even have heard of,
have enormous numbers of followers and can
very quickly persuade them of something that
is in fact quite, quite untrue about the nature
of the virus.
So in thinking about some of these different
ideas and conclusions that people may integrate
into their beliefs, again, depending on the
networks in which they participate, depending
on the media that they consume.
I want to try to link this back to something
I discussed with Jonathan Hite when he was
on the program, which related to sometimes
it seems as though people may vote or act
against their own personal interests.
And one of the ideas that Jonathan High and
others have introduced is that while it that
may be true, what may may not matter to a
greater degree is how much their actions fit
into the interests that whatever orthodoxy
or group they subscribe to has determined
is what's good for them.
A good example would be the Tea Party in the
US in 2010, where you had individuals seemingly
supporting a policy that would not be particularly
good for them because they weren't rich.
But it was still I don't know that I want
isn't there rational?
But we could understand the behavior better
if we understood how group motivations played
a role.
Does that apply to who is doing the protesting
against Lockdown's versus who is and who is
wearing a mask over versus who isn't this
sort of group analysis rather than individual?
Well, people have been thinking about these
questions for a long time.
Antonio Brumskine came up with the notion
of false consciousness when he was trying
to explain the failure of the proletarians
to line up in support of Marxism as an ideology.
And, of course, it was a recurrent feature
of European and American history in the 19th
and 20th centuries that working class people
stubbornly refused to support socialist parties.
So this is quite an old problem in social
science, especially for the United States,
where socialism was a sort of nonevent until
relatively recently and attracted very little
support.
I think if you if you're asking do people
act against their own individual self interest
because of an ideology or because of a sense
of a wider community?
The answer is yes, they do.
Again and again and again.
And that's partly because of the appeals that
can be made, whether it's to class identity
or racial identity or your ethnic identity.
These appeals are quite potent.
And by contrast, it's always a little harder
than it looks to establish exactly what your
own self-interest is in economics.
For many years.
We tried to imagine a rational, calculating
machine, homo economicus, whose goal was just
to maximize utility.
But as historians, we struggled to find these
people that really rather unusual and and
indeed not very popular when they do turn
up.
People like that exists, but you tend to find
them running hedge funds rather than being
your everyman.
So every man is quite inclined to be swayed
by collective consciousness, by ideas of group
loyalty when it comes down to behavior in
the pandemic.
I think there are two distinct forms of I'll
call it irrational behavior.
There's the form that says even although the
number of cases and hospitalizations is going
are going up in my state, I'm still going
to go back to work and I'm going to go back
to the stores and I'm not going to wear a
mask because the bells of hell go ting a ling
ling for you, but not for me.
In other words, people essentially don't think
they personally are going to get the virus.
Now, that may be because they're young and
they say to themselves, well, I've I've read
that it really only kills the elderly and
therefore my risk is pretty low.
But what's odd is that we find quite a lot
of older people who say in surveys that they're
in favor of rapid re-opening even before the
pandemics under control and in their area
on the side of people who recently protested.
It might be said that outdoors it's much harder
to catch.
Covered 19 than indoors and the most protests
are outdoors.
Therefore, there's not much risk.
But when you look at the crowds that pretty
densely packed and the shouting and we know
from the literature that the key to transmission
of source code, too, is it's not just talking
in a normal way, it's shouting and singing
that really along with coughing and sneezing
that propels the virus from a carrier to others.
So there's some risk involved in going to
these protests.
Most of the protesters are relatively young,
but I saw Mitt Romney out in the streets yesterday
wearing a mask prudently, but it's hard to
tell.
I've just looked at many shots and video clips.
I wouldn't say a majority of protesting people
have been wearing masks, and I wouldn't say
that they're all, as it were, young enough
not to worry.
In any case, even if you are young enough
not to be too worried about cough to you,
you should be worrying about the older people
that you're going to meet subsequent to your
protest.
Had a conversation, my daughter, about this
last night.
She's distinctly to the left of me politically,
but she had wisely resisted peer group pressure
to go on a march in London on the ground that
she would soon be seeing her mother and grandmother
who are in the vulnerable age group.
And so that that seemed like a pretty good
example of somebody coming to a good decision,
even under peer group pressure and peer group
pressures, a huge part of what's going on
here.
People may suspect they're doing something
that's not prudent, but they kind of give
in to the peer group pressure.
I was glad my daughter resisted that.
When it comes to beliefs about blame and responsibility
around the virus, there's definitely some
interesting network effects going on.
I was interested to see in your recent interview
with Andy Server.
I'll let you sort of characterize in detail
your position.
But at least generally speaking, you seem
to probably assign less responsibility to
the federal government than Trump's actions
than I would.
Although I do believe that there have been
unfair accusations also cast that the federal
government, which were either beyond anyone's
control or more relevant to a mayor or a governor,
for example.
What do you think are the unfair criticisms
that are or blame that is being placed on
the president?
Maybe we can start there?
Well, I think it's worth say right away that
the primary responsibility for this pandemic
lies with the Chinese governments and also
the provincial authorities in Hubei province
who really criminally failed to deal with
the problem and were slow to admit the extent
to which human to human transmission was happening.
I agree, Laide imposing travel bans until
it was really much too late.
So that's part one.
Part two of the answer is that the media obsession
with President Trump, which he of course encourages,
led, I think, to a tendency to overemphasize
the president's role in reality in a crisis
of this sors.
The agencies that really matter are those
responsible for pandemic preparedness.
And that is a part of the Department of Health
and Human Services, not just CDC, which has
got a lot of the stake.
But we have an undersecretary or I think an
assistant secretary, to be exact, at DHHS,
whose job this is and who had written and
spoken a good deal on the subject.
In fact, if you delve into it, the federal
bureaucracy had generated any number of reports
on pandemic preparedness and PowerPoint decks
with multiple slides.
And indeed, on paper, the United States was
well-prepared for a situation like this.
It was just that when it actually happened
back in January and right through February
and into March, that the agencies responsible,
the people whose job this was, did terribly.
And we can say that I think fairly, because
we can see where it was done much better in
countries where public health bureaucracies
were quick to respond, like in, for example,
Taiwan or South Korea or Germany, for that
matter.
You don't just need to look at Asian countries.
So the U.S. in common with I'd say also the
United Kingdom did really badly dealing with
a problem they were supposed to be ready for.
Making it all about Trump, I think, is a mistake
which misunderstands the nature of government.
It is not that the president sits there in
the White House with his phone ready to tweet,
deciding on everything.
That's just not the way it works.
The federal government's a hugely complex
thing with multiple agencies, more than 60
in total.
And there is an agency who has this job and
they failed and not nearly enough has been
written about.
That's in my view.
This is not to say Trump did great.
He did quite badly.
His decision making was erratic.
He had some good instincts, like we have to
do something about people coming in from China.
But it came much too late to make any difference
at all at the end of January.
And I think instinctively Trump felt that
Lockdown's were a mistake, which I think was
right, too, because it was an incredibly blunt
instrument to deal with.
The contagion are not necessary if, in fact,
you've done the right things early on.
So, you know, you can't say it's all his fault.
I think that's a great mistake.
But nor can you say he's done a great job.
I mean, in the end, the buck stops with the
president, the United States, as Harry Truman
said long ago.
And so one can't say what it was.
All the faults of DHHS, not the president's
fault.
He's the president.
Ultimately, the buck stops with him.
There's no question that the United States
has handled this pandemic very much worse
than it should have, very much worse than
other comparable countries.
And that is why we have the highest death
toll and may well end up with a very high
excess mortality rate by the end of the year.
So maybe we're not actually that far.
I mean, in hearing you laid out, it seems
like some of this is about the president as
the, you know, HHS run by Alex Azar, who early
on thought it was a good idea to put a former
labradoodle dealer in charge of the day to
day.
OK, that was a bad decision.
He is Trump's pick to run HHS.
So a lot of this seems to be the semantics
of Trump's delegation versus Trump's actions.
I mean, I think the biggest critique certainly
would be when you look at South Korea and
the US finding our first cases within hours
of each other.
South Korea, rapid test development fever.
Lennix isolation, contact tracing that happened
six weeks later.
Or it started to happen in a serious way,
six weeks later, the testing capacity was
a joke.
I do think, you know, you can't blame Trump
for one hundred thousand one hundred ten thousand
deaths.
Of course, there was probably a period there,
I would say, around, you know, aggressively
March 10th, less aggressively, March 25th,
where the request for a coordinated 50 state
stay at home, that would be long over by now
had it been done from the start.
And we wouldn't have what we now have rolling,
opening and closing.
Florida and Texas spiking.
Well, fortunately, here in Massachusetts,
we're doing well.
That certainly was a lost opportunity for
Trump.
And I would even say it was a lost opportunity
from a campaign standpoint.
I think that he has now suffered greatly because
he didn't do some of these things that may
have been economically unpopular at first,
but would likely have him with a much higher
than 38 percent approval today.
I wonder if you agree it's a difficult.
I'm not I mean, my sense is that by mid-March
it was it was too late.
And that blanket shelter in place orders would
not really have had a huge impact by that
stage other than, in fact, to magnify the
economic shock.
Let me reiterate, the key decision points
were in January, as soon as it became clear
there was a problem.
Yeah.
And right into February, when President Trump
and many others in the administration were
downplaying the threat, not only President
Trump.
Remember, at the end of January, when Trump
called for a travel ban on Chinese passengers
coming into the U.S., he was widely criticized
in the liberal media accused essentially of
racism.
And there were multiple articles at that time
in liberal circles saying it's just the flu.
In fact, you should worry much more about
the flu.
And for me, as somebody who was writing.
No, this really isn't the flu.
This is very much more serious.
It was maddening to see such ill informed
rubbish being published so widely.
There was a bipartisan failure to recognize
the scale of the threat that went on right
in February.
I can remember being in Washington in mid-February
trying to convince people in the administration
this thing is real.
You have got to do something and you particularly
have to tell the president to stop saying
there is no threat to the United States is
just going to disappear.
So it was it was then that I think the really
disastrous mistakes were made by mid-March.
They had been insouciant for so long that
they were actually thrown into panic by another
Neil Ferguson.
It's worth clarifying that I'm not him any.
I'll Ferguson, the epidemiologist at Imperial
College London, who published a report on
March 16, saying that if you didn't have Lockdown's
two point two million people were going to
die in the United States and half a million
in the UK.
And both the London and Washington governments
flipped when they saw this, as did many people
who saw the report or read about it.
And we went from total Insu Saelens to total
panic.
This was really the worst of both worlds because
we had dithered around when we should have
been taking early action.
And then we did a bunch of extremely blunt
instrument measures like shelter in place,
orders and economic lockdowns that it doesn't
seem to me have radically changed the spread
or slowed the spread of the virus.
Social distancing was something that mattered
a lot when people adopted that, even not at
the order of the state had a big impact.
The lockdowns have clearly done much more
economic harm than public health.
Good.
So, as I said, we've ended up with this kind
of worst of both worlds and it's not over
for me.
The depressing thing is seeing people behaving
all over the country as if it is over in in
defiance of the reality that if you just look
at numbers of of confirmed cases, there are
second waves already in about a dozen states.
It's already happening.
And so let me ask you that last maybe idea
that it's over.
Yeah.
So the last thing I wanted to touch on was
for a while I've been fearing that there was
going to be a point at which it's going to
be sort of unclear what each person should
be doing here in Massachusetts today.
Outdoor dining gets to open and then this
is phase two A and then we're going to get
to phase 2B where something else can happen.
And, you know, I don't know, I'm in my mid
thirties.
I I'm probably fine to go and sit outside
at a restaurant, but should I do it?
And is it if you need a mask.
Is this is that a signal that I shouldn't
be doing it?
Or what do you make of this phase?
Now that could last really it could last until
there's a vaccine.
I don't know how long it's going to last,
where there's going to be a lot of needing
to sort of figure out for oneself what is
the appropriate behavior.
Yes, I think you're right to feel confused
and uncertain because mixed policy signals
at the national and state level have created
exactly that sense of confusion all over the
country.
And this goes back to what we were talking
about earlier, when people are uncertain but
get their information from, let's say, more
sensationalistic sources, but then they will
take action.
That is, in fact, not going to help and might
even harm them.
Hydroxyl chloroquine, for example, is an example
of something that was touted as a remedy not
just by the president, but by many other people.
But the only really good scientific research
on this suggests that it has no real prophylactic
effect, that it's quite harmful if you are
suffering seriously from Kovar 19.
So as people try to work out what to do, they're
battling against a combination of poor quality
public information from the government.
I mean, I think our public health bureaucracy
has failed at the communications level, by
the way.
Really interesting piece on this subject in
The New York Times just about a week ago,
going through what exactly went wrong at CDC.
It's well worth reading, unlike many things
in The New York Times.
And it actually shows a classic pathology
of a Burack bureaucratic organization, very
hierarchical, very slow moving and easily
bullied by the White House.
When the going got tough, it is a very, very
stark illustration of a problem that the great
physicist Richard Feynman identified long
ago in the case of the Challenger space shuttle
disaster.
It's the mid-level bureaucracy that's often
the problem in disasters like this.
So we as individuals are getting poor information
from the public authorities and even worse
information from the Internet.
What are we going to do?
Well, we have to make sure that we read carefully
what is out there that is reputable.
That is to say, has some solid basis in scientific
research.
And on that basis, my advice to you is you
probably find to go and eat outside in Massachusetts
on a nice day.
You should wear a mask and you should really
keep your distance from from other people
as far as you can.
Just to be on the safe side, because Massachusetts
is a state where there is still quite a high
level of cases of cold 19 being diagnosed
every day.
Would I advise you to go into a crowded office
or to take a crowded form of public transport?
No, I'd say avoid those things.
Avoid any crowded indoor space, especially
if people are shouting or singing.
So forget choir practice.
And if somebody says, let's have a re-opening
party, come on round to my place, politely
decline because those are very likely the
super spreader events that we're going to
get in the coming weeks and months that will
keep this pandemic going in the United States
for much longer than was necessary.
Seems eminently reasonable.
I would say we've been speaking with Neil
Ferguson.
He is an historian and the new PBS series
Net World explores the history and science
of networks.
Neil, really appreciate your time today.
Thanks, David.
It's been a pleasure and enjoy that.
Enjoy that dinner remasters.
That's the problem.
That's the that's the logistical issue.
I will figure it out.
Thank you.